[Music]
hey everybody i'm lauren zima and I'm
Deidre Behar and we are counting down
the hottest couples of the year now it
was a very difficult decision narrowing
down who was going to make it on our
list but we have succeeded so we are
gonna name the top five cutest hottest
most amazing couples of 2016 but we know
you guys might disagree with us and have
some opinions too so leave your top
couples and et space book page comments
right now we will get them on our phones
and discuss maybe you're right and we're
wrong I don't know if we're about to
name them maybe Ashley's dad I get I and
it's not as fun i love the love we get
to do love today yes I feel like it so
you know there's a lot of sadness in
Hollywood and a lot of breakups today
we're just focusing on the positive yes
2016 was a rough year but love is still
real love is real now one couple that
proved that for us because they were a
surprise Union number five is Orlando
Bloom and Katy Perry here for that here
for it yeah couple love this couple like
you said unexpected never did I think
the 2016 Golden Globes would give me one
of my favorite couples of the year
chance encounter look at them laughing
and smiling that is the picture right
there and you guys this blew our minds
in the office I remember when this
happened because we see this picture of
them they're flirting in January at a
golden globes afterparty and we were
like is this real do they know each
other what's happening by februari
they're vacationing in Hawaii they're in
Hawaii they're kissing he's shirtless
they're holding hands it was fabulous
and I was on board for this I think that
he is Katie's type she goes for the brew
nécessaires actually dyed blonde now but
she goes for that they have the UNICEF
thing in common what do you think makes
them work I think it's that he's purely
a good guy I think that he's exhibited
he's a very loving and loyal father fun
fact I was once in a restaurant with
Orlando Bloom and it was just Deidre
Behar Orlando Bloom and a hostess and
the way that I saw him treat her just
kind of gave me an idea of his character
he was sweet he was chivalrous he was
friendly and I feel like he's may be
exhibited those qualities for Katie and
she just wants something simple I
thought John Mayer was maybe it for her
I wanted the Russell Brand situation to
work out I think it's maybe finally
Katie's time well they say that the way
that you treat service people are help
is very indicative of your character and
I think what's key about Orlando
is what you said I mean he's always very
sweet with our interviewers on red
carpets he's great with us and he is
mature because her type is these dark
haired guys these creative guys but
Russell Brand maybe a little too
immature John Mayer maybe a little too
much of a playboy orlando had our middle
narrowed had a child and still very sexy
o sino can I just point out really quick
the picture that Miranda Kerr took with
katy perry the fact that Orlando's X can
be with Orlando's new girlfriend i think
it just speaks volumes of the level of
maturity that we have here I appreciate
that especially for the sake of the
child and I also think that you can tell
another reason that they are one of our
favorite couples of the year is that you
can tell they're getting serious and I
think you can tell that because they're
kind of keeping things on the dl right
now you're not seeing a whole lot of
them on each other social media pages or
out in paparazzi photos I do know that
she's extremely family-oriented she just
went to dave and busters with her family
which is something I love doing um i
don't know i hope i'm hoping for maybe a
little holiday engagement if it's in the
works i would love to see that well
that's what I kind of want to get into
is so in January they met while we think
they met in January we see them flirting
februari they're on vacation in Hawaii
they keep it on the DL they have still
yet to walk a red carpet together but
they've been teasing us with these
apparent possible maybe alleged
engagement ring situations look at
Orlando's Instagram guys Katie's hand is
evident apparently we think it's katie's
han because we saw her wearing this ring
and other pictures just on the side
there it is that ring she rocked it on
that all-important finger and it's a
pretty sizable ring so I don't know I
would not be surprised if if they do get
engaged or are engage they seem very
serious now we also mentioned the UNICEF
thing so this is something they really
have in common they're both very
charitable they're both very active you
know Katie really campaign for Hillary
they both have their different causes
they're both involved with UNICEF now
they have not walked a red carpet
together but have been to UNICEF events
together and they both received the same
honor Katie this year Orlando last and
we want to get into some cute stuff that
they did tell us about each other just
in recent months here's what Katie had
to say about her man Orlando on the red
carpet I
I think every relationship is everyone
the teacher in a relationship that's how
I see it now and we've taught each other
in lock here oh I I just think that
that's so beautiful and again I feel
like I keep saying maturity but like I
feel like I see your band is singing
with glitter and I think of her is like
super youthful but then I see her say
something like that so eloquent so
polished they're both committed to being
people of the world and what's more
beautiful than them doing it together I
know that sounds cheesy but they're
together in Africa you know helping with
these children who really need them and
what bonds a couple more than that I
don't know I don't which I don't I
didn't well let's end on this little
note from Orlando here's what he told ET
about Katie she's you know I'm super
proud of the work that she does she's
she's she's a voice that speaks to so
many and and it's remarkable to see her
you know champion this calls just I it's
amazing we've happened to do this
together love supply oh you can you can
tell in his eyes and it is smile that
he's clearly very happy yeah of course
you guys your comments are already
coming in and you're disagreeing Carlos
says the only real famous couple are
Kanye and Kim and amanda says Zane and
Gigi Zane and Gigi I must admit are
definitely up there for us now they did
not make our top five and Kanye and Kim
spoiler alert they're not gonna be in
the top five here we tried to focus on
people who really had 2016 as their
breakout couple year truly all right
speaking out we're gonna dive into next
a couple that used to keep things on the
dl but kind of opened up about their
love a little this year yeah and I'm not
mad about it no I you know I think
justin timberlake and jessica biel
number or couple number four I think
that they're both so mainstream her as
an actor is him as an entertainer you
kind of give me a little more and I
think 2016 was the year that they did
that so first of all mothers day Oh is
there anything cuter than a guy calling
his wife a milf I don't think so let's
reveal exact quote Justin on Mother's
Day said of Jessica milf alert can I get
a little milf alert on this happy
mother's day to this amazing mom and
wife now that was just so sweet to me
and again you know it's playful it's fun
it's cute he post that picture of her
and this year was really about them kind
of coming out their life it was also
kind of Justin's breakout year into
social media
huh he came on Instagram this he warmed
up to it a lot yeah and a lot of
celebrities who are really a list on
that level don't really post about each
other on social media but just congested
diamond right in they are and you know
it's not as frequent as I would like it
because I don't want some bears I'm
sorry I'm think you have another couple
that's further down on the list that
kind of gives me things daily I do
appreciate what they do share with the
world because I know they are a very
private couple we very seldom see their
son Silas's face but you know let's talk
about the birthday post I thought that
was super sweet Justin's happy birthday
message read happy bay bay day bean
maybe I can't put into words what you
mean to me you are the greatest mommy
and wife a man could ever ask for I love
you to the moon and back your huz I love
you to the moon and back is there about
I mean greatest wife greatest mom anyone
could ever ask for he's really gushing
about her and we just saw them get very
public with their love at the Critics
Choice Awards on Sunday night this was a
date night for them they're out they
posed on the red carpet together there
they are there but look at the way he's
looking at her both smiling so big
holding hands on the red carpet we also
saw some off the carpet shots of Justin
casing at Jessica's hand it was so sweet
very PDA appropriate for the event I
just I I'm sorry I feel like we don't
really very often get to see so much out
of them as a couple and look at that was
the highlight of the night for me I saw
that picture come up on getty you know
we look at all the photos from award
shows on in getting images where they
all are and i sent that out to our
office email listserv immediately like
we have to write this up you guys the
way that he's holding her hand and
kissing it it's just it's so sweet it's
so sweet and sometimes when couples are
a little more quiet you wonder is
something going on like honestly with
Brad and Angie we hadn't heard from them
in a while and you know we were very
shocked by their split but because we
hadn't heard from them in a while we
were sort of thinking is something going
on but Jessica and Justin they weren't
always open about it but this year they
really came into their own they did and
can we get an honorable mention for
their halloween costume we're so cute
they did a little family costume
together trolls on during the movie he
did this year i hope that 2017 we're
gonna see more okay i want to see more
of Silas yeah you guys number three man
this is a couple was this who you're
talking about that just nerves us with
the love okay not but this couple to
done this quite often this Blake Shelton
and Wednesday
coming in at number three for us this
year I mean we know that they got
together being on the voice they talked
so much this year about overcoming the
tragedy of their divorces together about
how they awakened love for each other
interview after interview they are so
happy and I have to say I didn't see it
coming I didn't see it coming either I
didn't see the seriousness coming I'm
you know I thought it was entreat maybe
a remount your rebound but they are very
serious truly let's can we put up the
picture really quick of them making
their the red carpet debut as a couple
holding hands at the Vanity Fair party
this was almost a year ago almost a year
ago like you said I think this was the
moment where I realized this couple is
in it to win it okay they are hand in
hand what are the most serious loaded
you know Oscar events of the year and
and they pulled out the big guns with
their fashion and you can see that when
is sort of having her influence on Blake
and bling and sort of having his country
rocker influence on planet it really
melded in the most beautiful way their
lifestyles together mhm well we saw them
perform together on the voice they were
coaches together on the voice that's
where the love all started but since
then I mean he's been on tour she's been
on tour they have flown across the
country to meet up with each other and
to perform together and just look at the
way that she's looking at him that look
of love in there I they've written music
that's been in ya bite I think this song
was also another huge moment for them I
mean standing on stage gazing into each
other's eyes you could tell that the
love is real this is not just some
little quick fling type of rebound
action no and I think you know they have
both been very honest about the fact
that their divorces bonded them and
actually we were with when at the
glamour women of the year awards where
she was named woman of the year and
listen to what she told us about Blake
when she calls him naked it is just an
incredible year for me and I'm so
grateful you connected through music of
course with with Blake so you know how
has that helped you as well this year um
like shelf yeah that fella it's
incredible to have
a best friend like that guy he's an
amazing person a best friend you know
that counts for something because zach's
what's really gonna take your
relationship the the long haul you know
it's not just like oh we think each
other's hot or oh he just looks good on
my arm or she looks good on his arm
they're truly I think dare I say soul
mates oh my god very bold I think it's
really good but I think it's really true
and I think it's very evident in their
actions and in their behaviors
especially on social media can we talk
for a second about the ranch oh the
ranch Blake's ranch in Oklahoma I'm Gwen
Stefani from rocker the country chic one
hundred percent he's a little bit
country she's a little bit rock and roll
and she lost the red lipstick she lost
her usual crazy get ups and she just
went no makeup balls to the walls
hanging out in Oklahoma I mean look at
these videos that she posted to snapchat
her kids hanging out with with her
dancers her backup dancers are there I
mean this is as far from Beverly Hills
as you're gonna get truly I mean right
it's but you know remember she also
posted on snapchat she took him back to
her childhood home it's like they're
really getting invested in each other's
lives in who they are and what I like
about Blake for Gwen is when's fresh off
a divorce which I honestly think was
with a guy with Gavin who she saw
herself being with forever I mean we we
know that you know Gavin allegedly
cheated on Gwen um I don't think that
she was looking to end that marriage so
she shot herself with Gavin she was
heartbroken she said it was a tragedy
and she has found this guy who accepts
her with her kids with everything Blake
is mature enough for that and she spends
time with her kids the kids came to the
ranch and she's meeting his family to
one hundred percent i think it's been so
beautiful to watch how loving blake is
he's not a parent in real life it's not
like he can draw on his own personal
experiences to be welcoming to Gwen's
kids but it seems like he really treats
them as though they're his own he took
them to Disneyland earlier this year
riding on I don't even know what you
call that thing I know along the swamp I
just think that it's beautiful she said
her life blow up in her face and here
she is a year later just you know
couldn't be happier so radiant oh my
gosh and a lot of you guys are saying
Blake and Gwen should have been higher
on the list d says Gwen and Blake should
have been our number one I mean well we
know that they spent the holidays
together that Blake and his mom were
with granted thanksgiving she I don't
know if
met but spent time with his family there
so I think even more seriousness from
them next year potential so let me ask
you a quick question do you forebode a
holiday engagement for this couple that
is such a question right i think when is
the marrying kind i think so too and i
think that he's the kind to do it i
think so he's been married before it
would be a little fast but Gwen is it is
a pretty traditional woman I actually
remembered this interview when her and
Gavin first got married somebody asked
her favorite wedding gift and she said
it was like a set of knives that they
got she's pretty traditional so I see
her as the marrying kind we'll see what
happens alright moving on to number two
do you want to announce it my dear yes
we're moving into Blake Lively and Ryan
Reynolds I can't even count the amount
of times this year that they kind of
defined couples or relationship goals I
think chief among their milestones this
year would be the arrival of baby number
two we still don't even have the
pleasure of knowing her name she's just
baby number two but I think it's so
adorable that they just constantly
despite being the most beautiful looking
people on the planet they just remind me
of how human they are totally and that
they're just so not afraid to gush over
one another and I think one of the my
favorite moments of the year was when
Ryan was on Conan the baby had just been
born yeah Ryan was just on Conan the
baby had just been born and he
accidentally let it slip that it was a
girl Blake had no idea that he would be
giving such an omission and the way he
made it up to her was with her favorite
cookies from her favorite bakery in New
York City and he handed them to her with
an ice-cold glass of milk I know so
thoughtful so huge yes and it is I mean
he just said in an interview um earlier
this week that he had to think he's had
so much success this year he's been
named Entertainer of the Year at the
Critics Choice Awards Man of the Year by
GQ Deadpool was huge he'd been trying to
get that movie made for years and he
just said this week that he really has
to give her credit because she he said
was the invisible healthier without her
yes that she helped him develop the
character was so cute even on Father's
Day you know she the what she said I'm
in a read her Instagram was Ryan as a
father equals mic drop happy day to the
best one out there just simple and sweet
this is him as a man of the year awards
I'm on Thursday actually spoke to him
there and he had the sweetest thing to
say about Blake you know what though I
want to get in first to the birthday
celebration yeah I mean she throws in
the surprise birthday party we have a
picture of it do you want to read what
she it was so so cute what
wrote after she threw this for him best
birthday ever courtesy of my wife buddy
an international spy blake lively with
huge thanks to my favorite restaurant in
new york city and a special shout-out to
our children for not ruining everything
like they planned you know even also
this year told the story of how they
initially met and how they bonded and
they apparently just the two of them
shut down this restaurant and it was
just the two of them getting to know
each other their spark was just
undeniable the chemistry was palpable
and I just I'm sorry I have not enough
nice things to say about this couple I
think they're amazing to me a really big
part of the reason we put them on the
list this year was Ryan had such a huge
year again with Deadpool Blake with the
shallows that was a really big solo
project for her and they really showed
their humorous sides this year like I
love seeing how funny and sweet there
with each other he keeps like laughing
about the kids you know saying it's not
bothersome right but in this really
sweet adorable way um here's actually
what he said at that man of the year
event on thursday functioning family
it's amazing it's not my daughter take
care of the other words yeah
the lion king was right very last
question I admire your lovely wife
because she's posting on Instagram but
I'm just working out here I came back
she got Marty stood on I don't know what
your school is getting back in shape she
looks fantastic so um yeah I love that
he knows you know she's a perfect 10
that's basically what he's saying there
yes it he called the family the circle
of life so cute your comments love
coming in from blake and ryan from sure
a brittany says blake and Reiner number
one for me Letitia says i love those two
together and Marie says they are perfect
now Natalie just said John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen equal perfection Natalie
why do you say that Natalie they are our
number one yeah Oh could you think of a
couple that deserves it more I love them
so much they're literally the couple
that i was thinking of they give me
something to gush over daily not just
weekly I literally feel like at any
given moment I can go on snapchat or
Instagram and I can just smile so
effortlessly over something adorable
that either they've done or their
daughter Luna has done they just had the
best 2016 right another couple that
welcomed a child this year Luna was born
this year and they were very open and
honest about the fact that they had been
trying to have a baby look at her she's
waving hi John in that Instagram from
Chrissy so cute they tried for years to
have her in an april they welcomes a
little luna and they are just both so in
love with her this year they celebrated
10 years since they met Chrissy posted
this snap chatters keitel snapchat from
them ten years ago I met the best man on
this planet I love you happy anniversary
thank you so cute daddy Denny and
Natalie both coming in with number one
couple we agree and I mean honestly
Natalie you called it you did call it I
think what matters the most to me is how
John is not afraid to go to bat for
Chrissy mm-hmm she is a woman he was
very outspoken she's got a lot of
opinions I think after she was mommy
shamed for going out maybe a week or two
after Luna was born she looked superhot
they went to a hot spot in LA for dinner
only Chrissy was mommy shamed nobody
faulted John for going out only Chrissy
and he hopped on Twitter this is what he
said he said funny there's no dad
shamy when both of us go out to dinner
shame both of us so Chrissy doesn't have
to take it all we'll split it well I'm
what a point I mean preach I preach to
John Legend you know he's one of those
guys who is just you know I hate to said
I literally or some women call dads
babysitters like what he's babysitting
no you're a father you're a dad be
present and John Legend we have
interviewed him many times this year and
he has just gushed about how Luna has
changed his life about how he was so
wanted a baby but it's even more heart
filling than what he thought it's
inspiring new musics get so much love
coming in for them you guys Brittany
says I love Chrissy and John Donna loves
them so much love for them and like you
said they were on a date night that
night I love that they still prioritize
their relationship you have to yeah if
you don't you'll very quickly fall into
the trap of being mom and dad you don't
have to remember you were husband and
wife first yeah and they like I said
celebrated 10 years since they met we
saw that on snapchat and like you said
we get kind of that daily just they're
very open about their relationship and
Chris he actually told us that that's
really important to her we talked to her
on a red carpet earlier this year and
here's what she said about the fans and
sharing their relationship they've been
watching John
[Music]
is great
you guys we are her family she said it
hey talk about one of the most generous
and selfless celebrities a lot of people
like we mentioned before Justin
Timberlake he's very guarded with what
he puts up on social media Chrissy is
the antithesis of that she wants to feed
us more of John whether it's him making
mac and cheese or them giving Luna a
bath I mean there was nothing we really
haven't seen I thought the most adorable
thing maybe this year was when they went
back to the All of Me house in Italy
recreated the video we created that
iconic was a video which okay I'm right
here then of course poking fun at how
dramatic the video was yeah she said it
was three years later yes and then the
kind of cert quote circle of life moment
they recreated another music video
together she stars in his new music
video with little luna yes beautiful to
see their growing family together you
know once symbolizing your marriage when
symbolizing their family and like you
said that her and luna inspired his new
music they're right there in the video
you know he's I mean you can always act
in a music video he could be in a music
video with the model but you know uses
his own wife his own model I'm his happy
birthday message to her was so sweet
just listen to these words happy
birthday to my queen you are beautiful
bright funny passionate and so inspiring
your presence makes my life in our world
so much better she's not just good for
John she's good for the whole world the
Queen I really is so many reasons and
and thank you could be but a little
round receives forgiveness so much to
latch on to us younger one couple of the
year in you guys so Elizabeth says it's
nice to see couples fall in love and
have families every happy moment even
for the famous is nice to see love all
the top five thank you Elizabeth Carrie
says their precious love them um
couldn't agree more wouldn't agree more
and like I said we've interviewed John
and Chris you several times this year
and they're always so open to talking
about it I think we're gonna end we'll
wrap up after this but let's end on this
story of John telling us how he first
fell in love with Chrissy um we were
texting a lot and I started to see her
sense of humor and her we would talk on
the phone and I just started to fall in
love with how engaging and witty and and
and
funny she is and I think that's when I
really started to know that this was the
kind of person I want to be around a lot
and once we started spending more time
together between tour stops and all this
other stuff we realized we had such a
connection and then it blossomed into a
marriage and a baby Wow for her wit he
fell for her funniness well I mean I
felt hurt her over Twitter so I not only
imagine how funny of her personal text
messages were to him I just love that
though you know that's what he says
first is her wit or brain this is
someone I wanted to be around so for so
many reasons they are our number one
couple of 26 yes again yeah maybe a baby
next year we'll keep our fingers crossed
a little playmate for Luna Luna could
not be more beautiful so as many babies
as they can make turning about Donna
guys thank you so much for watching with
us again we know this list was hard to
make I mean some of you were saying
Miley and Liam Gigi and zany SES yes
love is still alive in 2016 yeah it is
there's a lot of couples that keep us
hanging on so we want to hear your
thoughts as always you can tweet either
of us and let us know II thought of the
list I'm at Lauren Zima I'm at her name
is Deidre and please keep like an ET on
facebook because we are doing a Facebook
lives all month long wrapping up 2016
counting down the year's biggest and
best stories scandals and more thank you
so much for watching keep the love alive
[Music]
you
[Music]